hi my name is Keith Lewinsky I'm an
adventure photographer and filmmaker
today I'm going to talk a little bit
about essential things I bring in the
field for every shoot there's so many
great apps that make photography so much
easier on the field one I really like is
Sunter they're what this app does is it
allows you to figure out where the Sun
is going to come up and where it's going
to set or even know that I'm scouting at
noon at six o'clock later that day the
Sun is going to go down there and I can
kind of pre build a composition I've
used split neutral density filters for
the last 20 years and they are an
essential part of my kit they go with me
everywhere they're pretty simple you
just slip them right onto the front of
your camera like any filter what they do
is they help combat situations where the
light isn't uneven I think this is an
essential tool that any photographer
filmmaker should always have they weigh
next to nothing and they can really make
an impossible shot possible
if I'm going out into the backcountry an
item that's become so household as the
GoPro I like to bring a stabilizer for
my GoPro the combined kit is incredibly
light it's great for run-and-gun
shooting behind somebody or in front of
somebody this is perfect I'm a big fan
of using off-camera lighting I like to
bring a full battery-operated light it
could be a small light or a big light
such as this and having an extra light
can really open up a lot of
opportunities to get photos that you
couldn't get otherwise
[Music]
you